no scientist who actually wanted to
retain any credibility would claim that
the correlation between rising co2 and
rising temperature at this very tiny
piece of time is proof of causation
correlation is not proof of causation
patrick mo welcome to the show
nice to be with you chris
what is your background how did you come
to be involved in the environmental
discussion
well rather checkered i have to admit
uh i grew up on a floating village on
the north end of vancouver island with
no road to that area it was a west coast
inlet so we were like outlanders there
and everything was by boat the freight
came on a boat once a week
uh to a village of about a hundred
people
and in 1965 when the road came finally a
75 kilometer gravel road from port hardy
on the other side of the north island
vancouver island is the largest island
on the west coast of the americas from
alaska to argentina so it's a 300 mile
long island
and i was born on it and still live on
it in a slightly more civilized part now
but i have a home on the beach where i
grew up so i'm really lucky that way
and uh when the road came we thought wow
now this place is just going to explode
half the people used the road to get out
so we learned something of human nature
that day
and i then ended up being sent to
boarding school because the one room
school i went to until grade eight only
went to grade eight so i was sent to
vancouver to st george's school which is
modeled after the
english public school
and uh there i excelled in science and
particularly life science
i went to the university of british
columbia in an honors bachelor of
science in biology and forestry which is
the industry i grew up in and it's what
we have almost on the entire province is
trees
and much of which is in parks and much
of which is in places where you're
allowed to cut them and make lumber and
paper
and so
i then discovered the word ecology
before it had been in the popular press
and realized it was an obscure branch of
science going back to the late 1800s
which basically dealt initially with
soil forming processes
and when you un when you understand soil
science you understand that all life
emanates from soil on the land that is
not it not in the ocean of course
but uh it it then led me to realize that
ecology was about the interrelationships
among all the factors on earth
especially with relation to life but
life is made of rocks and air and water
so it includes those too and all those
factors that come into effect so it's
almost like infinity the number of
interrelationships there are and
infinity is kind of a spiritual concept
because none of us can actually fathom
it and so as an agnostic in my family
my whole family was not particularly
religiously oriented i suddenly
discovered religion
in a
uh
non-religious sense in a way in science
i i discovered the the wonder of the
infinity
of life and the universe
and realized it was unfathomable
at a certain level but that we could
know more about it
uh by studying it and that's where i got
my beginnings and then i learned about
while doing my phd i learned about this
little group
that was beginning to meet in the
basement of the unitarian church in
vancouver to plan a protest voyage
against u.s hydrogen bomb testing in
alaska taking on the world's most
powerful organization at that time a
bunch of hippies and uh but we were
actually all professionals of one sort
or another just that of course we looked
like hippies because it was the hippie
era in the early 70s
and we sailed on that boat
12 of us
and
john cormack and his 12 disciples as we
called ourselves and
we caused quite a ruckus and got on
walter cronkite's evening news in the
united states
and helped change the course of nuclear
weapons
uh development it was the cusp of the
cold war when they stopped increasing
the number of nuclear weapons
and we stopped those nuclear tests on
amchitka island in the aleutians then
went on to campaign against french
atmospheric nuclear testing france was
still detonating hydrogen and atomic
bombs in the air in the southern
hemisphere in french polynesia and the
french people didn't even know this was
happening because france controlled all
the media including le monde
and we got in we got this issue in le
mans for the first time in france and
the campaign against that began
domestically as well as internationally
and uh oh just
the rest is history we stopped the
killing of thirty thousand whales per
year in the north pacific when we turned
from the nuclear issue having won two
major victories uh and then three four
years of campaigning
against the
ocean killing of wales by big factory
fleets it took that long but we ended
that uh by 1981
uh deep sea whaling was banned in all
the oceans of the world by the
international whaling commission which
is a branch of the un
and so we lobbied at the un and we went
out on the ocean and got in front of the
harpoons so we had footage of people
actually
trying to save the whale from being
killed by a harpoon that's what made
made it and that made us famous and then
we started making a lot of money and
then we hired a lot of people and then
we had a payroll to meet and then
as time went on the left sort of i guess
realized that there was money and power
in this new environmental movement that
we had helped create along with many
other groups but we were the only ones
that knew how to go we're talking about
greenpeace specifically as the movement
here at what point did it become
greenpeace
it became greenpeace right at the
beginning at the hydrogen test when you
went up to alaska yes when when one of
the people in the church basement
meetings
said uh as we were breaking up the
meeting someone said see you later
uh and said peace because peace then
meant sort of see you later
and uh someone's he said why don't we
make it a green piece
and so it started there so we named our
boat the greenpeace we nicknamed our
boat that we went to it was named the
phyllis cormack after the captain's wife
but we put a big sign saying greenpeace
on the front of it
on the cabin and uh
by the middle of next well early next
year the sa in 1972 we changed our name
from what it had been the don't make a
wave committee to the greenpeace
foundation
that's much foundation that's much
better as it goes yes foundation wasn't
because we were wealthy like foundations
are it was because of the asimov trilogy
uh about the small group of people on
the opposite side what star what star
wars is fashioned after
uh that that took on the empire and we
were taking on the empire indeed and
succeeded what about your exit
my exit was unfortunate but it was
caused by the fact
that as we became more well-known and
powerful and political
uh though we were basically hijacked by
the left in the end who were more clever
at politics than we were
as that was their game
and uh so i ended up being the only
director of greenpeace international
during the last six years from 79 when
we created greenpeace international and
i was instrumental in the negotiations
that brought that about
uh and until 86 when i left
i was the only director with any formal
science education and we were now
dealing with toxic
waste and issues of chemistry
and
you you don't need to be a phd marine
biologist to know to save the whales or
you don't need to be a nuclear physicist
to want to stop hydrogen bombs but if
you're going to get into the issue of
toxicology and now where they're calling
plastic toxic
right and calling carbon dioxide toxic
uh which is complete bs
uh you've got to know some chemistry and
you've got to understand toxicology
and because toxicology is not just about
something being poisonous it's about how
much of it does it take to be poisonous
which is known as the poison is in the
dose which is basically the first rule
of toxicology such like do no harm is in
medicine
the poison is in the dose
is and like for example table salt is
one of the best examples it is an
essential nutrient sodium chloride right
with chlorine in it
is an essential nutrient you die without
it that's why gandhi made salt at the
sea so they didn't have to pay a tax on
something that was essential for life
well
at a certain point it
gets to be too much and if you actually
ingest
four or five tablespoons of of table
salt all at once
you're likely to die because it becomes
toxic at those higher levels and you
also have at four or five tablespoons
sitting on the counter isn't harmful to
you
it's only harmful if you're exposed to
it
so there's a lot of issues in toxicology
that just got ignored in the whole thing
and then suddenly i find my other five
directors in greenpeace
agreeing that we should have a campaign
to ban chlorine worldwide that would be
our next big campaign
and it was based on the fact that
chlorine was a constituent of dioxins
ddt
and other chlorinated hydrocarbons
chlorinated hydrocarbons are a very
common group of elem of molecules
because carbon is the basis of life and
chlorine is essential as in sodium
chloride salt so there's lots of
chlorinated hydrocarbons around and not
all of them are toxic
uh at
at low levels and some of them are
but banning chlorine specifically uh was
such a stupid idea
seeing as though it is the most
important element for public health
adding it to drinking water swimming
pools spas as we use bromine also these
days there was a time when iodine which
is another one of the halogens in that
group along with chlorine was the most
important thing in your in your medicine
cabinet
as it was when i was a child if you got
a cut you put iodine on it to stop
infection
and so there's that reason for chlorine
the other reason is that 85 percent of
our pharmaceuticals are made with
chlorine chemistry and 25 of them
actually have chlorine in them if you
look at the ingredients in your cold or
flu medicines just for an example you'll
see a little cl after a lot of them
that's chlorine
so
at a purely
scientific perspective i couldn't stay
in a group that was going to
launch a campaign to ban chlorine
worldwide but that was just the sharp
end of the stick for some years
after a long evolution 15 years for me
from the beginning of being involved in
the beginning of the environmental
movement or the modern environmental
movement
we actually had a fairly strong
humanitarian orientation in the early
years we were trying to save
civilization from all-out nuclear war
and so that must means you care about
people
as well as the environment which was the
green part of greenpeace but the peace
part of greenpeace
was to end nuclear war or the threat of
nuclear war and we did a pretty good job
of helping with that
and but by the time i had to leave
the environmental movement now
controlled largely by the political left
had basically changed the tune to humans
are the enemies of the earth
humans are the enemies of nature
as if we are the only bad or evil
species on the planet and everything
else is either benign or good or
whatever you want to say but they're not
evil
right just so this is original sin
reinvented for environmentalism as it is
in
extreme christianity and i suppose other
religions i don't know much about other
ones but i do know that in christianity
there's a wing of it
that considers humans to be born with
evil in them uh
not that they don't have some good in
them but
i don't believe that one iota i just
think we're it's it's not even an uh a
relevant thing to discuss why do you
think that transition happened
from it being about peace to this alex
epstein calls it human racism
yes it's the same reason why americans
now think america is evil
uh even though they are americans
uh i i it's self-loathing is another way
of expressing it
um
it is a deeply
uh
destructive mental condition
to believe that you are evil even when
you're good
and
so i i that's what it is so why is it
why did it happen
fear of death i think is at the root of
it
um that's why
doomsday
predictions are made throughout history
is because people believe that when they
die the world will end because they
think they're so bloody important or
something i don't know what it is but it
is it is the fear of owns one own one's
own death projected on the universe or
or on the world end times apocalypse
they keep saying it's going to happen
they've been saying it for 10 000 years
or more this little guy standing on a
street corner with a sign saying the end
is near well they used to say the end is
nigh but i i think that's an english
term that nobody knows what it means
anymore but the end is near right and
that's what aoc is saying
and that's what
greta is saying and that's what the ice
ipcc is basically saying that's what the
world economic forum is saying that's
what biden is saying they're all saying
the end is near
because of climate change now now it
used to be because of the devil or
witches or something like that but now
it's because of climate change that the
end is near
and i'm sure it's a projection of one's
own fear of death
one of the reasons i'm sure of that is
that i don't think that way and i'm not
afraid of my own death
i have absolutely no fear of it because
there's one thing that you must do in
life is not to worry about things you
can't do anything about because then
you'd be worrying about way too many
things and you'd never get anything done
and so i only worry about things that i
can do something about
and
as as far as i can see i can't do
anything about the fact that i have
a
short life
on this earth short meaning under 100
years or so
it definitely does feel like
there's a narrative at the moment of
human racism of
the
descriptions of humanity being a scourge
on the earth people are made to feel
guilty about the cars that they drive or
the flights that they take or you know
you have greta thunder going back from
conferences on a
rowing boat and it's taking a six months
to get back across the atlantic
i don't know
i i think i'm unconvinced that
all of this
can be attributed to
the denial of death you know ernest
becker might agree but i'm not sure that
all of it could be but i don't know
where else it could come from it's
definitely a you know fear is a very
good control mechanism for people so
there are other
um
there are other powers at play there
however i don't understand why people
would take it and imbibe it themselves
and then start to push it back out
because if it's something that is that
makes you feel uncomfortable
i most people tend to to shy away from
it but it really does feel like
people have become their own torturers
with this you know it's almost
par for the course that humans are
damaging the earth that we're causing
harm and that we shouldn't be here
you said it uh and i i too
don't know if i have the whole picture
but i think that's part of it now fear
and guilt
you see those are the two that when
they're combined
are so powerful in controlling people
the way i put it is you're driving your
suv down the road you're afraid that you
were killing your grandchildren
by putting out the toxic co2 which is
actually the main food for all life on
earth why they can't get that i don't
know
but it is
it is a fact
and it is not toxic
etc but there is a fear and then that
makes you feel guilty because you're
killing your grandchildren right so fear
and guilt that's why i call the chapter
in my book climate of fear and guilt
and uh michael crichton used the word
fear in his book on climate change as
well
i forget the whole title but the word
fear climate it might have been climate
of fear but
uh
the the the fear that is put into people
about the end times you know and if
people would just think straight
they would realize that people have been
predicting the end times since
practically the beginning of time
and they have never
once been right
they are baton zero
on end times
right so why should we believe the new
end times story
well because this one's backed up by
science and it's got all of these people
around the world they all agree with
each other there's research there's
studies that have been done and you have
eighty percent of scientists say that
climate change is real
well
this is because lying has become
acceptable to a lot of people
bald-faced lying
it the the 80 thing or the 97 thing is a
lie it's been shown to be a lie in the
they you know this one study that said
it was 97 percent done by a psychologist
from australia
not a science not really a scientist
that's a a soft science at best
and he came up with this 97 percent
number when analyzed and this uh
christopher moncton was involved in this
reanalysis
uh along with a couple of other really
smart people on numbers and statistics
and it turns out to be 0.3 percent not
97 percent who actually
in their paper
declared that humans
will cause a climate disaster basically
many of them said humans have a role in
climate change
but they didn't say it was going to be a
disaster
so
that if you break down what people
actually said or even inferred
you will not find that many climate
scientists who will outright come out
and say this is a climate emergency the
scientists are hiding behind the
politicians who fund them
that's where they get all their money
they get their money from politicians
through bureaucrats in the deep state in
this in the united states i don't know
what you have as equivalent to the deep
state but having watched boris rise to
fame i can't
fathom what
caused that
so it must have been some kind of weird
political good hairdo that's what that's
what yeah right
let's not talk about that anymore um is
my attitude towards it because i just
watched these things somebody came out
today and said that polar bears are
inbreeding
right and that's because there's not
enough ice for them to find each other
anymore
oh yeah right
that's so weird
is that true that it well first what is
inbreeding right
is beyond cousins or second cousins
anything closer than that genetically
that's our definition of it yes but in
plant breeding for example and animal
breeding inbreeding is commonly used
in order to maintain characteristics
that are desirable but i've seen i've
seen tigers that have got down syndrome
from too tight inbreeding
yes but inbreeding is absolutely
necessary like you're not going to start
breeding with snails right
so
how far out does it go
well it needs to be within your own
species but not within your own
hereditary genetic pool yeah but
it should always be someone of another
race right because that's the most out
breeding you can get
right it should never be anybody in your
own race because that's inbreeding
you see inbreeding and out breeding are
flexible terms in that sense
there's extreme inbreeding
and there's extreme out breeding
right
if you out breed you water down
the genetics if you inbreed you
concentrate them
a combination of those two things is
always essential in species evolution
and
so therefore they're just using the word
inbreeding as a political term rather
than a scientific term there because
inbreeding is bad
period
right
that's that's how they're getting away
with that and the idea that they aren't
finding enough of each other the the
population of polar bears has grown by
four or five times since the treaty do
you know about the treaty on polar bears
so you do but nobody else does because
they never mention it they never
mentioned that in 1973 on the advice of
wildlife biologists because too many
people were now able to go to the arctic
in planes and hire inuit guides and get
polar bear rugs
there were too many people doing that it
was had become too easy and rich people
were able to easily do that
so the polar bear population was
declining due to over hunting
so
the all the nations with polar bears
signed a treaty international treaty to
end the unrestricted hunting of polar
bears in other words there had been no
restrictions on killing polar bears up
till then because there didn't seem to
need to be any because there was lots of
polar bears and hardly anybody ever went
up there and killed one besides which
they're really mean and horrible and
they'll kill you if you don't watch out
but with a high-powered rifle the odds
are turned in your favor
so
they signed that treaty and since then
the polar bear population has grown from
somewhere between six to ten thousand to
somewhere between thirty and fifty
thousand
those are the
accepted figures by all the people
involved in this except for
uh fakers which are not scientists right
they're polit political activists
give me your thoughts on extinction
rebellion
they're really really stupid and bad
elaborate on your thoughts about
extinction rebellion
well because you you come from right you
come from greenpeace co-founder of
greenpeace and extinction rebellion
there there seems to be people could see
some sort of lineage or progression or
connection you know it's an
environmentalist movement
no there's no lineage or progression we
didn't dress up like cult
teams of occult
movement like all dressed in really
stupid looking red uniforms that are
somewhere but a cross between the
inquisition
and
a cartoon
and spraying blood on buildings and
this sort of thing actually
i signed off when people started
chaining themselves to other people's
stuff
peace peacefulness pacifism
is non-violence right
but
it doesn't include inciting other people
to violence against you
that is not pacifism
in other words
by you making the first blow or you
chaining yourself to someone's tractor
who is trying to make a living with it
that is not peaceful
and yet
they they were basically saying that
anything short of killing the other
person is peaceful
almost you know it it's not peaceful
to interfere with other people's
livelihoods in a way that threatens
their livelihood that's not peaceful but
they think that they think that this is
a really important and just worthy cause
they need to get attention and people
aren't looking so they need to do more
so why don't they go with the taliban
that would be good then they'd have
machine guns and they could kill anybody
they wanted and have mass murder
uh to destroy the human race you know
that's more or less what they're
recommending as far as i can see
so i think they are i think they are
evil
there are good people and bad people and
people that are sort of in between like
actually most people are a little bit
good and a little bit bad
but these people are evil
that's what i think of extinction
rebellion what about greta thundberg the
other one of the other horsemen of the
environmental apocalypse
yeah well it's funny that people didn't
notice right away that she is a young
girl with pigtails
because
that's what stalin and mao
and hitler all used young girls
with pigtails
in their photographs it's all been well
documented
i don't know what the pigtails has to do
with it but uh
dictators all
often
it seems almost always use children
as as a front
to make it look as though
they're nice
i suppose i'm not sure what they're
she's danish though is there's someone
someone in denmark sending her over is
that some totalitarian leader in denmark
trying to get greta thumbberg to
no the movement is totalitarian right
and the movement the movement controls
her uh green she's she's she's there's
all kinds of photographs of her on
trains with the head of greenpeace
etc i mean and and of course al gore and
the list is endless
and her speeches are written for her
obviously
and she doesn't know anything much about
climate change or science
so what what is she then she's simply a
tool
right she is just a tool nothing more
she is not a wise person
telling us what we should be doing
she is being used
by hollywood actors
and phony politicians like al gore
none of none of whom actually have any
science
what scientist is behind greta thunder
toonberg i should say
it sounds like you've got a problem with
the delivery mechanism especially for
extinction rebellion and i can
absolutely agree with you there i don't
think that
going and
hammering and chiseling the front door
of banks or trying to erect structures
in the middle of london bridge i don't
think that that's a fantastic way to get
people on side simply from a human
psychology perspective if you want to
compel people to be a part of your cause
you need to convince them not terrorize
them
that being said yeah yeah but i mean
gluing your breasts to the street for
example has that happened
yes
gluing it gluing
your breasts like so lying face down and
and gluing your breast to the concrete
so that you can't be moved so that
you're blocking the traffic or whatever
okay right so that that's the kind of
thing they do and i i agree that it's
very sensational and everything but it
has absolutely nothing to do with the
issue whatsoever whatever the issue is i
don't even know what their issue is is
it that humans are should be
exterminated it seems to be that would
be basically their issue
and
so i recommended that a man glue his
penis to the top of a of a
subway car
and somebody did a cartoon of it on
twitter as a result of my suggestion
right so you can disagree one of the
five
unacceptable words either no no um
you can disagree with their methods but
there is an awful lot of
well-known people who appear to have
credentials saying that we are in a
climate emergency which we are aren't we
no
we are not
in a climate emergency
i don't know people say to me well all
you have to do is look outside
to see that it's a climate emergency i
i'm looking outside and i see a
beautiful green mountain with a glacier
on top of it where i live and a whole
mountain range right next to me and the
whole of vancouver island is as healthy
as can be and yet they say it's been
strip mined of all its trees no it has
not what do you think they mean when
they say climate emergency
i think they mean the end times are
coming
it's just another way of saying we're
all doomed
right because if there was an emergency
it means that if you don't do anything
about it you're doomed it got upgraded
right it was climate crisis and then
within the last couple of years it is
now climate emergency
precisely and i can't imagine what more
extreme word they could now invent
after they've come from
you know
crisis to emergency change
crisis emergency yeah there isn't you
are right there isn't much left but
there's there's so many
differing
critiques around what the impact is that
humans have had on the planet so the
world's getting too hot for instance
increases in the temperature that's
something that's happening is it not
the world has been warming ever so
slightly since about 1700 when the
little ice age stopped getting colder
and started getting warmer
there have been these thousand year
cycles for the last 6 000 years of the
interglacial period known as the
holocene which we are in now which is
about 12 000 years long
since we emerged from the last major
glaciation which peaked 22 000 years ago
which was one of 45 major glaciations
that have occurred during the
pleistocene ice age over the last 2.6
million years which is the first ice age
in 250 million years since
the previous ice age ended after a
hundred million years
from 350 million years ago to 250
million years
there was another ice age the previous
one to this one since the last 250
million years until recently
which was 2.5 million years ago
it was warmer than it is now at all
times
it is now colder than it has been even
in this interglacial period
during this pleisoscene ice age which
has gone up and down and up and down and
up and down
in cycles of 41 000 years for the first
1.6 million years and in cycles of 100
000 years for the last one million years
in concert with the two milankovitch
cycles
related to the tilt of the earth
changing and the orbit of the earth
changing shape
this is caused by the gravitational
attraction of jupiter on our earth
and so
these people want us to think that the
world began in 1850
when we started using fossil fuels
but for 150 years before that it was
also warming
and during one of those warming spurts
because when the earth warms it just
doesn't warm continuously it goes up and
then down and then up and then down and
then up and then down but net warming
net cooling looks like this down and
then up down and then up down and then
up there's cycles within cycles within
cycles
we understand very few of these cycles
we certainly don't know what causes the
onset of an ice age such as the one we
are in now
and we have no idea when it will end
because actually at the bottom level it
is still getting colder
and until we came along
only 150 years ago we started restoring
a balance to the global carbon cycle by
putting some of the carbon back into the
atmosphere
that had been taken out by life
and drawn down co2 to the lowest level
it has ever been in the history of the
planet which is 4.6 billion years
so when was the lowest
22 million years 22 000 years ago
co2 sank to 180 parts per million
due to the cooling
of the glaciation
causing the oceans to absorb carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere
the
liquids hold more gas when they're cold
and when they're warm
air holds more
humidity
in other words gas
when
gaseous forms of what can be liquids
holds more of it when they're warm like
warm air holds more water than cold air
does that's why fogs form when the air
cools because it condenses so it's the
exact opposite
water
and
in particular holds more gas when it's
cold
so when the earth cools
the oceans absorb co2 from the
atmosphere and the the total co2 there's
nearly 50 times as much co2 in the
oceans as there is in the atmosphere
today that wasn't always the case
because the atmosphere had a lot more
co2 in it in the past
going back 200 million years
it had about 2000 ppm
today it's 400 because of our
increasing it
from when we came along it was 280. so
you do agree that we as humans have had
an impact on the climate
no just producing co2 doesn't mean
you're having an impact on the climate
the primary impact of increased co2 is
more plant growth
and that's called the greening of the
earth and nassau has verified this with
maps on the internet and so has csiro in
australia which is the one they're the
one that broke it
in in
2014 or i think it was
when they showed a map showing up to 30
percent increased photosynthesis
due to increased co2 in the atmosphere
so that is the main known fact from what
has happened as a result of more co2 in
the atmosphere there is zero evidence
that the co2 increase in the atmosphere
is the cause of rising temperature
none whatsoever because it was already
rising as i was about to say during the
first 150 years of rising out of 1700
there was a period
of over 40 years
where the temperature increased
more and faster than it has done since
1850
especially since 1950 when we were
actually starting to put a significant
amount more co2 in the atmosphere
post-war
and today
it's exponential there's a wonderful
graph it's in my book which shows
the temperature record in central
england
from 1660 or so
when the first thermometer existed so
this is this is the longest
thermometer record of temperature in the
world because they were invented in
england
and so that shows a very steady
continuous rise in temperature of a
little over one degree celsius
in
320 years
it's not a big deal
certainly compared to previous like they
they keep saying it's never gone this
fast it's never risen this fast that is
a lie
it has risen this fast many times in the
even recent past especially from about
1690 to about 1730
it rose faster and longer than it ever
has done since
it's all in the record now they'll say
oh that's just a local
measurement well all measurements are
local measurements
but not if you aggregate them across
multiple right no that's called the
climate if you aggregate them across
global except global is really badly
skewed by there being by far the most
measuring centers in north america and
europe and hardly any in many other
places especially africa so
it even that is skewed badly in terms of
localism but never mind that
the fact of the matter is is climate
is a 30-year average of each weather
event right whether it's hurricanes or
tornadoes tornadoes are almost
non-existent in the united states this
year compared to previous years for some
reason the conditions just didn't happen
because the united states has 90 percent
of the world's tornadoes
there's a reason for that it's
geographic it's because from the arctic
to the gulf of mexico there are no
mountains in the way because that was an
inland sea
the prairies in other words
of the united states
were and of canada that was that was the
sea bottom at one point and so it's a
straight shot for arctic air to come all
the way down to the gulf of mexico and
for hot gulf of mexico air to come all
the way up and they combine and boom and
that's how hurricanes are formed too is
the convergence of cold and warm air
masses and that's why
when the earth warms
the tropics
hardly changes when the earth warms
the warming is
is
what's there not inadvertently is
greater anyways the warming is always
greater towards the poles when the earth
warms it wasn't that long ago when all
the arctic islands of canada were
covered in forest and there was giant
camels roaming there five million years
ago that's not very long ago
that that's five million years is like
an eternity to these people they don't
even know what it means
right so if we have
most of the effects of global warming or
of any warming that occurs at the poles
presumably that is going to increase the
melting of those ice caps is there a
concern whether it is
man-made or otherwise cyclical in nature
or simply a trend over time
should we be concerned about increased
warming rising sea levels we have a lot
of coastal cities we have people who
live there who may not be able to move
very easily
is that a danger
people who can't move very easily do you
have some of those are they in
wheelchairs or what
you have people who may i say i say two
things about this
number one
you won't have to run
right this is happening very very slowly
and always will happen very very slowly
it doesn't happen quickly
number two hire the dutch
right 25 percent of holland is below sea
level
and they're growing most of their food
there
on this land that is below sea level it
is not difficult to build dikes
around pieces of land
especially if the land is steep
sorry especially if the land is flat you
can save a lot of land by building a
foot of dyke or two
if the land is steep
you have to decide whether it's worth it
or not
to build a wall because you're only
going to lose a small amount of land if
it's coming steep out of the water so
those are the basic situations the sea
level has always been rising and falling
we should not weep because we happen to
be victims to this eternal factor
in the earth's
climate
and sea level
right the earth sea level has been 40
meters higher than it is today in the
past and it's been
a hundred meters lower
so it goes up and down but if you look
at the islands at the equator in
indonesia which are made of limestone
from ancient coral reefs
they're all undercut sometimes up to 12
feet
undercut they've got this angle undercut
they look like mushrooms right you may
have seen them in photographs vietnam
has them too they're all through that
part of the world where the islands are
made of limestone which is more erodible
than granite by waves
now
if if the sea was constantly rising for
the last 10 000 years or whatever
because it stopped rising pretty much
around 7 000 years ago when the glaciers
melted coming out of the last glaciation
the most recent glaciation it's not
necessarily the final one as people
think the last glaciation means the
final glaciation it just means the most
yes the most recent one of 45 that have
occurred in the pleistocene so we have
no guarantee that anything is going to
change another one should be here in 80
000 years according to the last million
years of cycles all which is
thoroughly documented
by ice cores from antarctica
so
this sea level rise and up and down has
been happening forever and people in the
last 10 000 years have adjusted to it
it's not going to like they they're
they're making it seem as though it will
be a flood
like an inundation right
that's the climate emergency
scenario that all of a sudden our houses
will be under water
it's not going to work that way and
that's why obama is perfectly happy to
buy a 14 million dollar house right on
the ocean
in cape cod
because he also knows this
that he's safe there
there's some inland
harbors in the uk
isn't there under some
ruins of of roman
shipping
places that are actually miles in land
from when the sea level was higher
precisely and that was 2000 years ago
when the romans built docks on all
across the south of britain
and
louis
you know where lewis is no
well it's one of those castle towns
on a river that flows south
it's way inland
it was on the sea
also there's a place in france
called something sirlomaire
it's like
many many kilometers from the sea today
it used to be a harbor
so
it appears as though
the sea level is lower today
and that would be worldwide
than it was 2 000 years ago
and
that is because the world was warmer
2000 years ago during the roman war
period that's why they have a name for
it because it was the roman war period
and in the roman war period two thousand
years ago it was warmer than it is today
in addition during the medieval warm
period one thousand years ago
interestingly a thousand years a
thousand years a thousand years this has
been the trend there was also a thing
called the minoan warm period before the
roman war period
the earth has been cooling for 6 000
years net cooling we are in a slight
upward tick now it's just an upward tick
in
a downward movement do you think that
we've got further to go down
yes 80 thousand years further
the milankovitch cycle so
thousand years so you think that
realistically we are seeing this upward
tick
what has happened is it has coincided
with an increase of releasing carbon
dioxide which has led some scientists to
associate the increasing temperature
with the increase in carbon dioxide
which justifies blaming it on humans but
that if you were to roll it forward by
another
500 years
you are going to see the crest of that
thousand year cycle actually
diminish
and we're going to start to cool again
and then cool again to a lower level
than we would have seen previously at
the previous low you got it
if things continue on the same pattern
they have for the last six thousand
years which is typical of an
interglacial period through the
antarctic ice cores
we have a really good picture of the
last eight hundred thousand years and
now they're starting to go back more
than a million years into the times when
there was a forty one thousand year
cycle
right now we only have really good
information for the hundred thousand
year cycles especially going back
through four of them they all have names
the previous one was the eemian
i'm forgetting the other two right now
but they have names on a chart
and they were a hundred thousand years
apart
in quite perfect synchronization we know
the co2 levels and the temperature
at the antarctic during those cycles
because we can measure proxy
measurements of isotopes and actually
the co2 is measured directly from
bubbles in the ice
down
400 000 years in ice
and so we've got that and we know
that the interglacial periods
come out in
10 000 years
whereas and then there's a 10 000 year
this these are not all equal exactly
right but approximately 10 000 year
interglacial period
where the temperature remains higher for
a period of time and then a gradual 80
000 year decline into the next major
glaciation so it appears as though and
the and and the interglacial periods are
virtually always warmer at the very
beginning of them in other words as you
come out
of the previous glaciation
it goes up
to what we call the holocene climatic
optimum
meaning it was warmer than
for the first six thousand years
of the holocene interglacial period and
since then it has been cooling this is
well documented the graphs are in my
book they're from iceland and antarctic
ice
cores and they're also from marine
sediments marine sediments can take you
back half a billion years because stuff
has been falling on the bottom of the
sea from all the life in the ocean
and the st and the sediments flowing
into the ocean in addition so the life
that dies falls to the bottom and is
embedded in the sediments that come from
the land
and that record is in layers and we can
date all of that with radioactive
techniques
so
we've got that
what do people mean when they say that
we've got 50 harvests left
is that like 50 years of crops currently
yeah i think so i don't know why they
wouldn't just say 50 years of crops as
opposed to 50 harvests because that's
just confused me but yeah let's call it
50 years of crops left what do they mean
is that something you can do with soil
microbiomy stuff or biomass stuff
environment stuff
no it's it's simply a cult doomsday
prediction
is what it is
they have absolutely no reason to say
that
there's no oil degradation none of this
oh yeah topsoil degradation it's
happening everywhere no we're our
farming methods are
so improved now that soil conservation
is so improved now
that we're not losing soil like they say
we are and yes soil gets washed into the
sea by rivers right
new soil is created
it's not as if soil creation has ended
and people think that trees use dirt to
make themselves
and therefore if you take the trees away
over and over and over again by
harvesting them the soil will eventually
go away right no the soil is made by the
bloody trees
that's how soil gets there if there was
no trees that would be rocks there no
soil soil doesn't just happen by itself
it happens because of the leaves falling
and the branches falling on the ground
and decaying
and some of it turns into soil soil
forming processes was the beginning of
ecology in the steps in the ukraine
studying the grasslands of the ukraine
which are very productive deep churnazem
soils have been created by grass
doesn't it's not just trees that make
dirt it's all plants
make dirt
and
when you look at a tree and you see this
huge say at a big mature tree you see
this huge solid thing
it's hard to believe that it's 99 made
from air and water
right the carbon and the hydrogen and
the oxygen in that tree which is over 99
of that tree's biomass
came from carbon dioxide and h2o water
that's what made it trees are basically
carbohydrates so are we except for our
bones
and so
the the
the knowledge of of life is so poor
science has progressed so far
and yet the average person's knowledge
of science has degraded
because they're being told all these
lies
that carbon dioxide is poison when in
fact it is the primary food for all life
and there isn't enough of it
right now
and there certainly wasn't enough of it
when we first started putting some back
it's important to note
that all the carbon that we are
releasing was made by life
in the form of fossil fuels and much
more importantly in the form of
carbonaceous rocks
now have you heard of carbonaceous rocks
i have not
of course you have it's called limestone
and limestone is what we make cement
with
and limestone is calcium carbonate
it is a carbonaceous rock
the carbon in limestone came from co2 in
the ocean
and the co2 in the ocean came from the
air
so as
the shelled creatures evolved what we
call the marine calcifying species
all life in the sea was microscopic
invisible and unicellular until about
600 570 600 million years ago
then the cambrian explosion occurred
which was the advent of multi-cellular
life in the sea
and large creatures this big
came into being if you read
steven
uh
ghoul's
book
a wonderful life you will see the
history
of early life as discovered through the
burgess shale which is a fossil deposit
in the rocky mountains at yoho national
park in canada the chinese have a
parallel one
where soft bodied organisms were
preserved
because most fossils are bones or shells
because they were hard parts
and they could be preserved more easily
soft parts would normally decay
but because of mudslides which
immediately ended oxygen exposure
ancient creatures that were only soft
like jellyfish
were preserved as fossils so there's a
record of these species evolution in the
early times of the cambrian
at a certain point
many different species somehow from a
common thread
develop the ability to combine calcium
and carbon dioxide
calcium like sodium and potassium is in
the salts in the seed
and
combine calcium with carbon dioxide to
make calcium carbonate
to form shells
armor plating
around their soft bodies like oysters
and mussels and crabs and barnacles and
shrimp and tiny coccolithophores which
are a plant phytoplankton and a little
bit larger foraminifera which are but
they're an animal they're about the size
of a very tiny grain of sand
and they are all marine calcifying
species
coral reefs are actually the predominant
one which is about 50
of all the calcification going on in the
world and was much more before when
coral reefs were much more widely spread
when the earth was warmer they've been
reduced to basically
small places where the ocean is still
warm enough for the high biodiversity of
corals the particularly indonesian coral
triangle
and so
today
we have a situation where these coral
species and other calcifying species are
still
using the carbon dioxide out of the
ocean and it's raining down on the
bottom
as dead shells
right as shells from dead creatures and
that has built up and formed all of the
car
all of the limestone in the world over
the years and that's where most of the
carbon dioxide has gone
ninety percent approximately only about
ten percent of it has gone into fossil
fuels now the fossil fuels are also the
result of forest being buried and turned
into coal
of species sinking to the bottom the the
soft parts of species turning into oil
and gas
in and now we find them on the land in
places like texas which was once a sea
bottom
and
and the fracking
deposits all were at one time a sea
bottom
whereas the coal deposits were a
terrestrial environment where forests
but all of the fossil fuels were made
with photosynthesis they were all
created by solar energy they were all
created by carbon dioxide being drawn
out of the atmosphere and locked away
for hundreds of millions of years where
the plants on the land and in the sea
could no longer use it because it was
gone into these locked up sediments they
call it sequestration
or sequestered carbon
it is out of the cycle
that's why co2 came down to such a low
level
at the glass glaciation when the oceans
cooled and pulled it out of the
atmosphere to 180 which is 30 parts per
million above the death of plants
plants don't just need co2 just like us
they need a certain level of co2 just
like we need a certain level of oxygen
if you have an atmosphere with five
percent oxygen you die
actually you die at 10 oxygen i think
it's even higher than that whereas
oxygen is around 20 in the atmosphere
but you go up to the top of mount
everest
and you've got to be a sherpa who's been
doing it for their whole life before you
can breathe up there
and successfully live
so
these are true truisms about life that
they need a certain level of their
essential nutrients and carbon dioxide
being the key essential nutrient for all
plants
they need it at one 130 150 and they
start to die and it is believed that
during some of the last major
glaciations because of ash layers that
are associated with the peak of those
glaciations that high altitude plants
did all die and burn
because they were dried out
and
that would be because when you ru when
the higher you go the thinner the air
gets
so even though co2 is still at the same
parts per million compared to the other
gases it's more dispersed
and therefore more difficult for plants
to obtain that
everything i'm saying is thoroughly
documented on the internet
the and and the most important point is
that no scientist
who actually wanted to retain any
credibility would claim that the
correlation between rising co2 and
rising temperature at this very tiny
piece of time is proof of causation
right
correlation is not proof of causation
correlation just means two things are
going in the same direction and very
often the reason they are is because of
a third common factor and let me give
you an example
the relationship between
ice cream consumption and shark attacks
they are perfectly correlated
when ice cream consumption goes up shark
attacks go up
ice cream consumption goes down shark
attacks go down it's a perfect annual
cycle
do ice cream consumptions cause shark
attacks no
do shark attacks cause ice cream
consumption no
this is a correlation which is not
an example of causation because
temperature
a third factor is the cause of both of
them going in the same cycle
when the temperature gets warm people go
to the beach eat an ice cream and go
swimming and some of them get attacked
by a shark
in the winter neither happens so this is
correlation is far more common than
causation and there's a a website called
something correlations spurious
correlations yeah that one yeah
yeah like nicolas cage correlated with
the number of people that die by being
caught up in their bedding every year
there's a statistically significant all
right so what's the third what do you
think is the third
factor in that case
is there something that oh there doesn't
have to be one
there doesn't have to it's just that
they're both right there could be a a
separate factor causing temperature to
change and a separate factor of powerful
conditions yeah causing co2 to change
and the fact that they're both going up
at this time but they're not going up in
sync
if you look at there's one graph in in
my book that shows that in this
interglacial period
we came before humans started emitting
we came to a point where co2 was at 280
and temperature was at a certain point i
don't know what exact celsius it was
and then suddenly co2 just shoots up off
the chart if you put it in a hundred
thousand years graph
this little bit of time right now 150
years and really only the last 60 or 70
where it's been substantial 60 years of
inc of radical increase in co2 i won't
you know say that's wrong it is a
radical increase we don't need to do it
this quickly
and that is why in my book i make it
very clear that reducing fossil fuel
consumption would be an excellent
strategy
if you had something reliable cost
effective to replace it with
right and that is nuclear energy
with nuclear energy we could easily take
out half the fossil fuels being used
today not because of climate change but
because they're precious
and should be conserved because they're
non-renewable they don't they're not
being made as quickly as we're using
them by orders of magnitude right so we
should be conserving fossil fuels for
the essential things like flying
airplanes it's not easy to fly an
airplane with anything else besides a
liquid fuel and liquid fuels are hard to
come by as are gaseous ones like methane
natural gas
so
electricity is mostly being made by
fossil fuels today not just in china
it's only in france that more than 50
percent of the electricity is being made
by nuclear energy
and they they dis france for this and
they hold up germany as a shining
example of green
when in fact germany is emitting nearly
two times the co2 per capita of france
and their only reason france is emitting
less co2 is because of nuclear energy
why is the world so averse to nuclear
energy
because they're idiots
and they're they're brainwashed and
whatever else right
i have nothing but
contempt for people who just
reject nuclear energy when almost no one
has ever been killed by it except
chernobyl which was a stupid reactor
design that the russians made from their
plutonium production reactors to make
nuclear weapons they just cookie
cuttered the same cheap reactor all
across
the former soviet union all of which
have been shut down in any of the former
satellites they still have 10 running
eight or 10 running in
in russia but they have modified them so
that can't happen again they should have
done that in the first place because
they had a negative void coefficient or
a positive void coefficient i never get
them right but one is good and the other
is bad
and
their reactor was a design that could
theoretically
go critical in other words
become a nuclear bomb
and that slow one
that was a slow nuclear bomb that
explosion they happen faster in real
nuclear bombs and do more damage than
that one did but it blew a 2 000 ton lid
off itself a concrete lid and then
burned because they had a huge
carbon moderator in there that was 2 000
tons or something uh too i mean there's
big numbers involved in chernobyl and
that burnt for 10 days while
firefighters tried to put it out spewing
more and more radiation into the
atmosphere the whole time
whereas three mile island wasn't even
worth talking about it was a bad
accident accord a core meltdown but it
didn't cause any damage to anything or
anyone
and no one died in fukushima from
radiation and no one will because no one
received a sufficient dose to cause any
harm and this is confirmed by the
radioactive effects research foundation
in hiroshima and nagasaki formed after
the second world war by macarthur and
the japanese to study the life history
of people who were exposed to the
radiation and survived aren't there some
tuna or some fish in the sea who are
showing higher levels of radiation and
ten eyes two yes ten eyes imagine that
no
there are not there's higher levels
means
infinitesimal higher levels if that's
what they mean they did have a ban on
fishing in the region because a lot of
liquid was going into the water that was
contaminated as they say had radioactive
substances in it there are radioactive
substances in you and me potassium 40 in
particular if you eat a banana
which is radioactive we have radiation
stuff wasn't from a banana was it that
was from something much more dangerous
well what do you mean what was more
nuclear reactors are not inherently
dangerous they are if you eat them
yeah but we
we don't eat them and nobody ate
anything from fukushima because they
stopped taking crops from the land
nearby i mean they took the fukushima
was one of the stupidest accidents that
ever occurred in the world and the
japanese are so insular in their culture
that they did not take the the lessons
that were learned from other accidents
that occurred they just didn't and the
the difference in culture can be
explained this way in the united states
or britain when a reactor has a problem
the operator phones the prime minister
and tells him what the problem is and
what he's doing to try to fix it
in japan
the operator phones the president and
asks the president what he should do
right because he's the president
and he doesn't know what the heck to do
so those three explosions that happened
one day after another i think
approximately at fukushima
could all have easily been prevented
even after the meltdowns occurred
because they were hydrogen explosions
people think those were explosions in
the reactor they weren't they were
explosions of hydrogen gas that was not
released as it should have been to
prevent it from becoming concentrated at
eight percent hydrogen almost
spontaneously ignites with any spark and
causes a huge explosion so and then they
evacuated to all the people even though
they were not subject to sufficient
radiation to require evacuation and over
2 000 people died from the evacuation
because they evacuated five intensive
care wards into gymnasiums in other
communities where they did not have the
facilities to keep them alive
so that that's the kind of overreaction
that happened to in fukushima which was
a bad accident it was a huge industrial
accident but it did not cause death what
caused death of almost 20 000 people was
the tsunami
and i saw on cnn
a headline written across the screen
during the fukushima
disaster which said
nuclear crisis deepens
as bodies wash ashore
that's what it said
and that was to me the beginning of fake
news all the way when they started
showing
smog and calling it carbon dioxide
basically
and showing backlit
chimneys of factories with black
smoke coming out of them supposedly but
no it was water vapor and that's what
water vapor looks like when you
backlight it
so
the the
and you know and the same with the
inbreeding polar bears i mean they are
just making up one story after another
now and floating it in the media and it
all comes back to the fact that the
politicians
are funding the scientists to give them
what they want which is something that
they can instill fear
and guilt into the population about in
order to have power and then the media
and the activists are the bull horn
right the megaphone
that
puts that into just a giant global story
and nothing else matters the truth
doesn't matter one bit anymore in this
discussion what about the people that
say we're seeing the beginning of the
next big extinction event
it's so stupid
we're not seeing the beginning of the
next big extinction event
okay if a big extinction event was
happening and it was being documented i
could get it but read the chapter in my
book on extinction where i appeared
before
a committee of the u.s house of congress
with three people there claiming to be
united nations scientists
saying that yes
we only know of 1.7 plus million species
which have been identified named
photographed written up etc but there
are very likely 8.7 million species
that's what they said
there's probably 8.7 million species and
this is our best estimate
where did they get that estimate
thin air there's no way you can turn one
point 1.7 into 8.7
without having any actual observation of
any real thing so they were saying
there's about seven million
unreal species that we don't know about
and then they say and a million of those
will go extinct in the next few decades
right how many of you how many of the
observed creatures
have they seen go extinct
an ever decreasing number as humans in
around 1920 when the passenger pigeon
became extinct
suddenly
the general population took an interest
in the issue of extinction
prior to that which wasn't very long ago
100 years
nobody cared about extinction they
thought it was a normal thing except a
few naturalists who
bemoaned the extinction of the dodo bird
or
other species that went extinct as a
result of human activity
and most people don't realize that the
main cause
of species extinction is not hunting
right it it is actually agriculture
and the changing of habitats
so that is why most
species recovery programs are based on
habitat and making sure that there's a
place for these species to exist
that's key
but we have not like overrun 90 of the
world's habitat and much of the
area that we are using especially for
forestry
is perfectly suitable for most of the
species that always lived in the forest
agriculture is different
agriculture creates a monoculture on
purpose and that's pretty hard to get
away from people who preach that you
should have 17 different species of
plants growing on the same plot of land
i'd like to see them do it successfully
it's not possible
so they the farmer wants to get rid of
every insect every animal
you know everything other than every
other plant
all other all other plants are weeds
in this case
and so agriculture is is where you have
to really
look at what you're doing in the
landscape and make sure that in that
landscape and it usually happens
naturally if you fly across the uh whole
agricultural area of the united states
you see lots of forest interspersed
among the agricultural land because and
europe too i mean most people don't
realize that
200 years ago 250 years ago less than 10
percent of europe remained forested
because the trees were being used for
everything to do with fuel they were
being used to heat all the buildings
to smelt all the iron and copper to do
the glass works
and steam engines everything was fueled
by wood and all the building of
everything so forth started to disappear
in central europe initially and then
spreading out over the whole of europe
the first time in the history of humans
where forests
were disappearing we were cutting them
faster than they were growing back
that's why agriculture was invented 10
000 years ago and forestry wasn't
invented until about 1750 in central
europe because they realized they had to
start planting some trees
and then silviculture otherwise known as
as forestry scientific forestry came
into being and now there's 43 percent
forest cover in europe well speaking of
trees i thought i thought the amazon
rainforest was wrecked
ten percent of it has been modified
that's great that could be quite a bit
it's a fair big forest isn't it it's a
huge forest and it's not in any way
endangered
the the problem with the you know my
book is titled fake invisible
catastrophes and threats of doom for a
reason i put the word invisible in there
because to most people the amazon is
invisible they show you a picture of a
fire that takes up the whole screen
right it might be about 10 feet
of the you know of the amazon which is
almost as big as the continental united
states brazil itself is almost as big as
the continental united states and amazon
is a huge part of brazil
and
there are parts of the amazon
that have been developed but most of it
is intact
and even where it's been developed it is
only small areas if you just look at a
satellite photograph of it you can see
it i've flown over it in an airplane at
fairly low elevation and you go for five
hours and you hardly see any people
it's called a human desert by people but
even
you know the the leader of brazil now is
under attack over the amazon
from the left
and one of the reasons you can get away
with that is almost no one in brazil has
ever been to the amazon even though it's
in their own country
people don't go there
what would you do there
it's got manos which is basically a
manufacturing hub for electronics so
it's a sort of a
tax-free zone of some kind
you've got balaam at the mouth of the
river which is i've been to that city
it's not very interesting it's just a
city at the mouth of the amazon and
there's not much else to do there
you can go on a boat up and down the
river
and then you see all you see is trees
the whole way and the amazon
is 300 miles wide during the flood
period it will never have a bridge over
it
it doesn't have a road anymore
because the road the plants grew up
through the pavement and destroyed the
road within 10 years when they did build
one to minnows i'm gonna guess that if
we continue to increase the
concentration of carbon dioxide that's
just going to happen
quicker yes the amazon is is growing
faster but interestingly it's the drier
places that benefit most from increased
co2
because
increased co2 has two effects
one more co2 for growth
like
i'll give you the second one in a minute
but first i digress to say that i used
to laugh at people who said their plants
grew better when they talk to them as if
plants have ears and can hear you and
are empathetic or whatever
and so i sort of chuckled at that then i
realized that when you're talking to
your plants you're breathing 40 000
parts per million co2 on them that's our
breath
is a hundred times the level it is in
the air
so you're basically breathing super
concentrated fertilizer onto your plants
when you're talking to them and they do
grow better because of that because they
would like to have more co2 than exists
in the natural world today
the second thing that increased co2 does
is it makes most plants more efficient
with water
because now it's easier for them to get
the carbon dioxide they need because
it's more concentrated in the atmosphere
and therefore they don't need to make as
many holes in the bottom of their leaves
they're called stomata
it's where they take in the air with the
co2 in it but it's also where they lose
water through transpiration
so the fewer of those holes there are
the less water they lose therefore the
more efficient they become with water
and gives them ability to survive in
places that have less water than they
could before that's why trees are
marching out onto grasslands in many
parts of the world the south west of the
u.s for example and australia
the very eastern part
of
sorry the very western part of australia
western australia as it's known
is the driest part of australia the
nullabar desert is there too which
doesn't have much of anything growing on
it because it's so dry but in the in the
west like around perth and down to
albany the the trees are growing much
faster now and so are the crops
because
they you know if if you're a farmer
today and you are giving your plants all
the water and all the fertilizer they
need the
mineral food the limiting factor to the
plants growth is carbon dioxide because
of how low it is in the atmosphere even
today
and the proof is in the pudding here
because all commercial greenhouse
growers
in the world
inject carbon dioxide into their
greenhouses because they have an
enclosed space where they can increase
the level of co2 and they generally go
up to between 800 and 1200 ppm
which even above that the plants grow
faster but there's a curve because
economics is involved they have to buy
the co2 so at this level at right
somewhere in the curve they say okay
1200 is optimum for us because above
that buying more co2 has an ever
decreasing increase in yield
and so 1200 works really well in
greenhouses that's four times sorry
three times what it is today in the
global atmosphere and that is
we should not even be concerned
until co2 gets up to 20 000 ppm
because that's what submariners survive
in for three months underwater
and the the the people who uh had the
trouble on apollo 13 where the co2 was
building up it went up to at least 20
000 in there see our breath is 40 000.
we have 40 000 ppm co2 in our lungs just
before we breathe out i don't want to be
breathing that in though
yes you do
what the same air that i breathed out
well in that case you could no no just
once just once yeah yeah but you don't
want to be a closed system of breathing
that backing when you put your mask on
you are breathing a significant portion
of the air you just breathed out back in
again
so we we can survive at a whole
different bunch of levels of co2 just
fine and plants are happy with it at 10
000 ppm or they wouldn't be here because
that's what it was back 500 million
years ago one of the things that i
decided to fact check you on or internet
check you on was photos of the great
pacific garbage patch and photos of
birds with plastic inside of their
stomachs i'd seen these floating around
on the internet and when i was reading
your book and listening to you i found
that you'd said try and find me a photo
of a big patch of garbage that doesn't
have mountains in the background
because in the middle of the pacific
there aren't any mountains that are
nearby so if someone was to take a photo
of it something that's supposed to be
didn't someone say it was nearly the
size of texas or something like what's
the size of texas and growing faster
than anyone ever predicted yes um and i
thought well if this thing's so big
that seems ridiculous i'd seen photos of
big clumps of plastic floating together
bottles and
and stuff in the middle of the ocean so
i did a search and i kept on looking in
the background and people have
re-cropped numbers of different photos
and twisted them so that they look like
they're at different angles i thought oh
that's
that's kind of interesting because i
thought i was pretty sure that that was
there and then the other thing that you
mentioned was
birds that birds don't have teeth so the
way that they digest their food is
actually by putting little stones or
nuts into their stomach and their
gillett and then they use that to grind
up the food
and then they eject the little bits of
plastic back out so i thought well i'll
have a bit of a read about that and i'll
have a look and i'd seen a photo sort of
a carcass of an albatross and it's laid
on the floor and it's really just sort
of
bones and some feathers
and it's got like a thimble like a full
reel of string inside of it and other
stuff and you'd mentioned that a lot of
these might be staged and i thought yeah
no no not a lot of them not a lot of
them chris all of them okay i looked and
i thought were the skeptical i was like
yeah i mean that that one does look
a bit ridiculous and then a few of the
other ones do and i read an article from
i want to say it was that bbc
one of david attenborough's
documentaries about life or something
and it's one of the right ups that's a
partner to one of the episodes in the
episode you see one of the birds eating
plastic and i was like okay well maybe
they're doing this thing maybe no you
don't
not in his episodes you don't see a bird
eating plastic oh it might have been
it's definitely a documentary on the bbc
um yeah he's holding up a plastic bag
next to a chick in a nest okay
and saying
adult birds are feeding plastic to their
chicks there's no pic i've i've searched
the internet thoroughly he's actually
removed one sequence that sequence where
he's holding up the plastic bag it no
longer is available on the internet i
don't know what this thing yeah it what
did you say the first time if about a
year ago if sir before i wrote my book i
i think he's on to me uh
and
he he's he's an absolute liar in many
many cases and i've made three of them
in the book
one of them is that albatross adults are
feeding plastic to their young
mistaking it for food greenpeace says
the same thing the smithsonian institute
in the united states is saying the same
thing they are pushing this lie
that albatross can't tell plastic from
food
sir david attenborough never mentions
the word gizzard anywhere
he wrote the bloody secret life of
bird's book
he
did a 10-part series on bbc on birds
right
and he doesn't know that birds all have
gizzards that need to have solid objects
in them to grind their food because they
have no teeth and therefore have two
stomachs all birds every bird in the
world that's why all land birds
take pebbles into their stomach and when
their chicks are in the nest and can't
go and get pebbles for themselves they
put pebbles in their chick so if you
have a more convenient pebble that is
made of plastic and it's able to do the
same job then no the land birds do not
feed bits of plastic to their chicks as
far as i know because there's plenty of
pebbles but out in the ocean where birds
are actual marine animals that nest on
rocky islands barren rocky islands where
all there is is a bit of grass right
there's no pebbles there either
so traditionally their favorite well
naturally they feed their chick squid
little squid
in those squid is a beak
that beak is retained in the gizzard
as part of the digestive aids
right it's like a ball mill in mining
where they put steel balls into a mill
to grind the ore it's exactly the same
concept in many ways but in the in the
gizzard it's a muscular motion where
they go like this with their gizzard and
grind the food with these solid objects
in there to help with it
and so the other thing they'll take is
pumice
which is volcanic lava from undersea
volcanoes and because it's spongy it
floats it's got air in it or gases in it
so it floats so little bits of
pumice will come to the surface
sometimes in huge layers when a undersea
volcano goes off but they're not it's
not always there so they have to resort
them to hard bits of wood and nuts that
have dropped off a plant in a river or
by the seashore and come out in the
ocean so it
they have to work really hard
to find enough digestive aids that are
suitable in size and and hardness
it's not easy for them and when plastic
started showing up in the ocean 60 years
ago
they started choosing pieces of the
right size not plastic bags not
cigarette lighters not spools of yarn
that's all staged they don't feed them
those kind of things and they're
actually they're not feeding the plastic
bits they're giving it to them to ingest
so they can put it in their gizzard
that's where it goes they know how to
decide which goes in which stomach so
the story that i read
had this lady explaining about the
situation and that the parents she'd
used the word feed she'd parents had
come back and given their chicks these
plastic pebbles and i can't remember the
word that they used uh to describe what
happens
as they're just about to fly the nest
some bird wood
the bowlers
maybe that
they cough up most of the hard objects
in there because the reason they have so
much in their gizzard is because they
will digest their food even faster then
and the parents won't have to feed them
for the rest of their lives
right so they want them out of the nest
as soon as possible so they put a lot of
plastic which weighs a lot plastic and
but plastic is never a majority of
what's in
a young bird's gizzard never like it's
shown in those stage photos it's like
all plastic what this lady said was just
as they were about to leave i saw them
eject the the the plastic back up and
throw it back up just because they were
about to leave the nest and yeah it's
not just the plastic not just the
plastic but all the other items they
have in there to do the same job and
it's all plastic is always a minority of
it and she's got all these plastic bags
and big plastic plastic cloths and
things that's all staged yeah well
that's not going in it's not going to
fit in a small bird is it no it well
they're not they're actually quite big
because albatrosses are big but it's not
going to it's not going to work
they only if you see the photo in my
book the only photo i know of of a adult
albatross
giving plastic to its chick you can see
it in its beak going into the chick's
mouth and it's all nice little pieces of
colored plastic
that are just the right shape and size
it's not plastic bags it's not
cigarette lighters like they show in the
staged pictures but when you read that
when you read that article what you see
is if you didn't know that the birds
needed the plastic to break up food in
the stomach if you didn't know that that
was something that aids them with that
digestion and that it is common for them
to throw up the plastic plus presumably
all of the other stuff that's been in
there helping them to break up their
food you would read that article and it
is it is accurate what she says is
correct but the things that have been
purposefully omitted
and the understanding about why some of
the inclusions have been put in there
and why biologically that might still be
natural
that creates a situation and that was
the moment i was reading it and i
thought
this really is
this really is quite sinister it does
feel like it's quite a
manipulative way
to tell people what has happened but
frame it in such a manner that makes us
again hate our own existence
you could say evil
as a synonym of sinister
and i believe it is because sir david
attenborough also lied about the
walruses committing suicide due to a
lack of ice
that's the final chapter in my book they
committed suicide was this a harry carry
thing
yes they jumped off a cliff to their
death
in order
to
avoid an attack by 20 polar bears oh
he didn't mention that part and that is
well documented there are photographs of
the bears the people who live in a
nearby town know that the reason the the
walruses left off a cliff was because
they were being
about to be attacked and eaten by polar
bears what was the proposed reason
not enough ice
as if you can put those two things
together it's sort of like polar bears
are inbreeding because there isn't
enough ice as if those two things are
connected somehow right and he made it
seem as though it was connected that
there was because he said the reason the
polar bears have come on the land
and got to a place
where they could jump off
they did
because there was no ice for them in the
sea below which is always the case on
the north shore of russia the ice
recedes in the summer
and funny enough he says that the he
says the ice is their home
no
the sea is their home
that's where the walrus lives and fishes
they don't fish actually
they dig clams
on the bottom
and when the ice recedes away from the
coast
and they are coming out of the water to
haul out they come on the land there's a
reason why it is an officially
designated walrus sanctuary this piece
of land and he implies that it's
unnatural that they are coming on the
land because there's not enough ice for
them to get onto
when in fact they cannot exist they are
a coastal species they cannot exist deep
sea
so if the ice recedes to where it's 600
feet deep or 1000 feet deep it's no good
to them
because
they are bottom feeders and as i say in
my book they are bottom feeders much
like sir david attenborough and his tv
crew on the planet earth or whatever our
planet right there they too are bottom
feeders in this case
and they are lying because the reason
the walruses left to their death
fell to their death
they didn't walruses can't actually leap
but they plummeted to their death
because a pack of polar bears was going
to eat them
and instead the polar bears just walked
down to where all the dead walruses were
and ate them while they're dead and i'm
sure the walruses would rather be eaten
while they were dead than while they
were alive so that's the deal there and
he is bald-faced lying to the whole
world about this and he continues to do
it he had people in davos in tears
recently telling this story even though
he now knows that i have busted him and
so has susan crockford the polar bear
expert who's also an expert in all
arctic animals has busted him publicly
and he sticks to this story because bbc
lets him
right
patrick moore ladies and gentlemen fake
invisible catastrophes and threats of
doom will be available on amazon in the
links of the show notes below if people
want to keep up to date with all of the
other stuff that you're doing where
should they go
you will perish in flames that's what i
have to say about that
there's a little man
on the front who's the little man who's
the guy who's he's supposed to be
made-up guy made-up guru
right but you will perish in flames is i
i stole it from the ghostbusters
i don't know if you remember the scene
where
uh
the the short guy maranus
approaches the horse and buggy in
central park and first goes up to the
horse and says
are you the key master or something like
that right to the horse and then runs
off with his eyes blazing
screaming at the driver you will perish
in flames
so uh that's that little guy how many
people have got how many people have got
donald trump
quote quoted on the back of their book
talking about oh no no he's not quoted
he's quoting me
yeah yeah but it's he that's him on the
back of your book talking about your
work there's not many people that must
have had that
uh i was very pleased that he recognized
that i was telling the truth
about carbon dioxide being the primary
element for all life
etc and that there was no climate
emergency or crisis as it may have been
called at that time pretty impressive
that was an appearance on tucker carlson
uh yeah what have you got a website do
you have a twitter or anything like that
yeah i got a twitter it's ecosensenow
uh and it's it's i got nearly 100 000
followers they dropped back about 10 000
when a lot of people quit twitter
uh
and but i've stayed on and i just
recently i said i'm quitting twitter
finally because the taliban is on it and
they're kicking all these other people
off who aren't the taliban
and uh people i had about a thousand
people come back and say stay man stay
so
because we need you here and so it's
very difficult these days to know when
you should like with the
the uh
vaccine
issue uh i i know that in law and in
medicine
informed consent has always been the
rule that nobody is required to consent
to any medical treatment surgery
needles
uh pills
right
without their own consent
everybody has a right as an individual
to refuse treatment in other words
and they're trying to turn that on its
head by threatening people with their
livelihoods and with their ability to be
a normal person they might as well stamp
a brand on their forehead right
and
make them second class citizens is what
they're doing and so
people are saying to me well why did you
get vaccinated then and
et cetera well because i want to be
but i respect the right of other people
not to want to be and actually on
gutfeld
he had trump on the last two nights
and trump made that same point because
his wife doesn't want to be vaccinated
and
gutfeld and trump came to the conclusion
that that was perfectly her right
that is the truth if we don't if we
allow
society to force us into medical
treatments maybe next they'll want our
skin to make lampshades you know
so you that this is a fundamental
principle in medicine is informed
consent and in law
and they're trying to bust it down so
that they can have control over
everybody to say what they should have
to have injected into their bodies and
personally i believe the vaccines are
efficacious i also had kovit was in the
hospital for six days
really sick
after i had my first vaccination it had
not yet taken effect or i was one of
those people who gets it anyways but
it's
normal
after two vaccinations at least you're
95 percent immune and now i'm
must be close to 100 immune because i
survive covet but they don't take that
into account so the fact that they're
not taking covet survivors as equivalent
to vaccinated people is also another
travesty in this whole thing so i i it's
like climate it's like the climate issue
in some ways
um but it's even more
bizarre from a political control point
of view because they're really pulling
the levers here you know and trying to
make it so that all all of their
subjects are
are subject
to their whims and we got to fight that
and so people are blaming me for not
fighting it because i'm got it
vaccinated so it's really complicated
that way from an intellectual point of
view as to
should i join even though i've been
vaccinated should i join the
anti-vaxxers in a march you know no i'm
not anti-vaxxer
right
and neither is trump he's vaccinated
uh well he brought us the product
apparently
maybe a conversation for another time
patrick thanks so much for today
thank you very much chris nice to be
with you thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace